What would be a fairly common side effect of taking Ivermectin and Fedbed is all?
Well common thing that people can have is
I would even say it's common a few people have said that they've had some stomach upset if they've taken it on an empty stomach
That has been corrected if they take it with food, so that hasn't really been a problem
The side effect that isn't necessarily a symptom, it's more an objective fighting, is
Notaceted elevation and AST, ALT, or alkaline phosphatase those are liver enzymes and I believe that for the most part
It's the fenbed is all that's doing that we have some people that have been just Ivermectin not Fedbed is all and we haven't seen that
phenomena at all we've had people on Fedbed is all and not Ivermectin and we have seen that phenomena and we have seen it with people on both
So I think it's the Fedbed is all that's the culprit that can that can be more of a liver irritant remember your liver enzymes your ALT
AST and alkaline phosphatase could be elevated we're all sorts of different things
But they certainly could be elevated if you're if the liver is
Be irritated let's say it that way so you could be it is these things are still drugs somebody asked a question a few weeks ago
Should I just take you know I have I don't know if they're asking for somebody else
But they said if I don't have cancer can I just take Ivermectin just you know to help
Decrease by chance for cancer and I would say no I mean these are still drugs
I wouldn't take them prophylactically
You're taking them for a purpose and for a treatment
It also means that you're not taking them for the rest of your life either
I know there's websites out there that say that that are people are taking Ivermectin and they've been taking them since COVID days
To keep from having COVID or to prevent from having cancer
I just don't think that's the way to do it
I don't think that's the way to use these medications
I think they could have other side effects that
That can be harmful to your body and they can certainly be toxic to your liver
so
You know doesn't mean that it's a bad drug it doesn't mean that you're you
Um
Have to stop using it forever, but if the person has elevated
Liver enzymes I want them to take a break on their femenital you just have to take a vacation from it
Two weeks four weeks whatever we need to get those liver enzymes back in order. We certainly don't want to be
using a medication like this or a supplement
Rejimate or anything you know chemotherapy and have the drug itself have the quote-unquote cure of the cancer
hurt you uh and bring your demise that's just silly so we just need to use things wisely
And we need to be looking at objective tests to see if
There if it's negatively affected your body and if it is negatively negatively affected your body
You need to pause it for a period of time. So
That's the why is way to use any medications